the last rehearsal before the big moment
the children's choir practices its song
to greet the Coptic Pope big and smaller
like a very excited we want to see him
he loves us all and we love him I'm very
happy toward roast the second is on his
first visit to Germany since he took
office a year ago
almost all of the 200 members of the
Coptic community in Berlin have
relatives in Egypt they're afraid for
them in view of Islamist violence
against Christians their Tawadros tried
to allay their concerns the majority of
Egyptians are moderate regardless of
whether they're Christians or Muslims
and the relationship has been basically
good for 14 centuries we are working
hard to maintain this good relationship
tawadros his visit has given Cox a rare
chance to meet their new pope in Egypt
we can't get as close to the Pope
because there are so many bodyguards
protecting him here it's different this
feeling is hard to describe our joy is
boundless because the Holy Father comes
to visit perhaps once in 10 years in
toward roses visit is an early Christmas
present for Berlin's cops who don't
celebrate Christmas until January 6th